in this video I will demonstrate how to
create new custom standard drivers with
IT NCM IBM Tivoli network configuration
manager before starting the
demonstration I will provide some
background on IT NCM drivers and I will
briefly discuss the information that
should be collected in advance prior to
creating a new driver ID NCM ships with
drivers for a large number of network
devices for devices that are not covered
out of the box IT MCM provides a wizard
to create new custom standard type
drivers standard drivers are CLI or
command line interface drivers that
provide basic configuration back up and
configuration change functionality new
smart model type drivers cannot be
created using the driver creation wizard
it is usually possible to create a new
custom standard driver for devices that
have a CLI interface that is directly
accessible by a telnet or SSH it may be
difficult or not possible to create new
custom standard drivers for devices that
require navigating a menu to reach the
CLI interface or they make significant
use of special characters in their
interface it is not possible to create
new standard drivers for devices that
only have GUI or API interfaces for
configuration management IT MCM is
intended to manage network devices such
as routers and switches but depending on
your requirements it may be possible to
manage specific aspects of other devices
such as Linux servers in this video we
will create a driver that can collect
the output of a set of commands for a
Linux server and that can execute simple
CLI commands on a Linux server the basic
steps to create a new standard driver
are the same for all device types with a
CLI interface keep in mind that if you
need comprehensive server management iBM
has products that are better suited for
that task in order to work efficiently
when using the driver creation wizard is
important to do some planning for your
new driver I won't review the decisions
you need to make and the data you need
to collect before starting work on your
new driver first what values will you
use
vt MOS the vendor type the model in the
OS version you cannot use a vga MOS that
is an exact match for a defeat a MOS
that already exists in itn CM you should
also consider how your choice of bt mls
will affect selecting devices and other
IT MCM resources when using bt MOS
filters in this example we will use a VT
MOS of linux server sent OS 6x
it is possible for drivers to support
multiple models and OS versions if the
behavior in CLI commands for those
models and OS versions are very similar
in this example we will support one
model sent OS and two OS versions five
star and six star next decide how your
new driver will verify the model and OS
version information when communicating
with the device typically you need to
identify CLI command output that
contains exact or wildcard matches for
the model and OS version strings there
are ways to map or replace strings found
in the command output but we will not
cover that topic in this example in this
example we will use the output of the
command cap slash UTC / red hat -
release since that output contains
matches for both the model and the OS
version strings you must know the
sequence of prompts and responses used
when logging on to the device you will
need to edit part of the driver to match
some or all of that sequence and finally
you need to decide what you consider if
the device's configuration to be we need
to be able to collect this data from the
device and store it in itn CM in this
example we will capture the output of
the commands cat / etc' slash hosts and
net stat - NR this slide provides the
output of the commands used in this
example for determining the device's VT
MOS and for collecting the device's
configuration data you may find this
data useful to refer to during the
demonstration of creating a new custom
standard driver we'll launch the new
driver creation wizard by navigating to
the system manager tab the draw
diverse section and then from the Tools
menu we'll select new driver when the
new driver window opens select IBM
templates then select CLI based via
telnet or SSH we are not going to
demonstrate creating tl1 based drivers
in this example then click Next and then
the driver details panel we enter the
data that we decided upon earlier so our
vendor was going to be Linux the type
was going to be server the model was
going to be sent OS and the OS was going
to be 6x the supported model would be
sent OS and the supported OSS we're
going to be five star and six star both
the supported models and the supported
OS values are comma delimited lists
we'll click Next to move to the device
script section device scripts control
the configurable details of the
handshake between IT MCM communication
handlers and the device for
functionality such as logging on
executing commands and transferring data
we're going to edit the SSH session of
the device script since our Linux server
only allows SSH connections we will
select an existing device script
template by using the selection boxes
near the bottom of the screen in this
case we'll pick a Cisco router 7200
you
and eversion 12.3 we're using a Cisco
router template because there are no v
TM OSS in IT NCM that have behavior
really similar to a Linux server and
with Cisco routers 7200 family of
drivers as an SSH connection section
that will work pretty well without
extensive modification note that if you
have a custom device script that is
closer to the behavior of your new VT
MLS you can always paste in that script
from the text mode of the editor will
click open to load the device script and
once it loads we'll make sure that we
have the SSH tab selected and that we
have the form editing mode selected
advanced users may prefer to use the
text mode of the editor however you must
navigate the device script manually and
be sure that you're editing the correct
section when you use this mode in this
example we're going to use the forum
mode the first section we will edit will
be the connect section this is the
section that handles logging on to the
device we will use information from the
device logon sequence to edit the
section since we are using SSH
programmatically it's likely that we
will only need to know the prompt that
indicates that we've successfully logged
on even though this section is designed
to handle telnet as well as SSH we will
also need to remove any extra lines that
are specific to the template vgm OS to
avoid executing commands that do not
apply to our target device well first
edit the script content to remove the if
ENDIF block that handles the enable
command for routers since this does not
apply to linux servers
next we'll remove the lines that control
setting the terminal width and length on
a Cisco router since these also don't
apply to a Linux server finally we'll
change our prompt from a pound sign to a
dollar sign since in this case we're
logged in as a non root user and we'll
be seeing the dollar character as the
last character in our prompt next we'll
edit the section of the script that
parses the model information from the
device output we've already decided that
we will use to Ed put up the cap et Cie
Red Hat release command to provide the
VT mos data that will parse in this
section we'll edit this section to
reflect the information from the output
of that command
you
note that in order to have a good match
in this case we've included a carriage
return line feed character after the Red
Hat release line that comes right before
the Santa a string which is a model and
we've also included a leading and
trailing space after the word release
next we'll edit the section that
determines the OS version we'll click on
the config dot version tab and edit that
information also using the output of the
command cat / FC slash Red Hat release
the concept of feature sets doesn't
apply to the OS versions of Linux
servers so we'll delete those lines will
change the rest of the lines to match
what we see in the output of FC Red Hat
release
in this case we want to identify or
parse a at the string 6.7 s OS version
so our find begins string will be sent
OS release with the trailing space
and our find end string will be a
leading space followed by opening
parentheses next we'll edit the section
that pulls what we consider to be our
running configuration data from the
device we'll click on configure unning
we want to send the command capped /fc
slash hosts and net stat - NR to the
device we need to edit the commands that
we want to send in this section and the
prompt that lets us know when we've
received each command response we also
need to add information strings to parse
for that indicate the start and the end
of the configuration data so we will
paste in the commands we want to send
first note that we are sending an echo
command to Ed put as a start marker we
use the echoed string as the find began
value in the upper panel
note that were also
with a line feed character so that we
can avoid including the actual echo
command itself in our configuration
output data this is not required having
a start marker and we're simply doing
this to show an example of how this can
be done also note that we don't put a
final weight equals dollar sign
remember the dollar sign is the prompt
we're looking for we do not put an a
final weight equals dollar sign line at
the end of this set of commands because
we want to catch the final dollar prompt
as our config dot running dot end marker
both to tell us that we've received all
the data and when we're parsing for the
end of the configuration data next we'll
edit the information or diag section
we'll click on the diag tab this section
allows us to collect additional
information from the device in addition
to what we consider to be our
configuration data
unlike configuration data historical
versions of this data are not kept only
one copy of this data per device is kept
the database field that stores this data
is fairly large but if the collected
data is too large for the field it will
cause a driver error and the entire unit
of work for the device will fail we need
to edit the commands that we're going to
send in this section and the prompt that
lets us know we have received each
command response we also have to add a
string to parse for that indicate that
we've received all the informational
data in this example we'll send a single
command slash sbin such ifconfig will
also change our prompt that indicates
the end of data to the dollar sign
character
note that we don't have a weight equals
dollar sign because we want to intercept
the final dollar sign character at the
end of our data however if we have
multiple commands as we saw before we
edited after each command except for the
final command we would have a weight
equals dollar sign line to make sure
that we'd received all data from the
first command before we started a second
command next we'll edit the device
script section that controls sending CLI
commands to the device using native CLI
command sets these commands can either
make changes to the device or return
data from the device or possibly both in
this example we are going to send
commands to the device in line in the
SSH session with the device the section
of the device script used for this
purpose is the stream file section CLI
commands resulting from processing a
native CLI command set or store it in a
temporary file and this section handles
streaming the lines from the temporary
file to the device we will remove the
existing commands that are intended for
a cisco router and replace those or
leave only the commands that are needed
for a linux server
you
we'll also change the prompter waiting
for two our dollar prompt next we'll
edit global settings for the device
script will select the miscellaneous tab
will change the prompts to match our
dollar sign prompt and we'll add a line
that strips the final line off the
configuration data this is an optional
line this line may or may not be useful
to you depending on your data and
whether or not a trailing line is a
problem for your use of the
configuration data next we'll edit the
config tag again global data or global
settings will change the configuration
type to single config since we don't
have the concept of a start up and
running configuration on a linux server
and will change the prompts to our
dollar prompt even though these values
are probably overridden by specific
script sections this completes editing
the device script so we'll click Next to
move on to the resource access or read
section since we plan to use SSH to
communicate with our Linux server will
select the SSH tab and make sure it's
enabled
in the transport section we'll make sure
that our streaming put and get check
boxes are checked this is because we
want to send and receive data over our
SSH connection stream rather than
creating an FTP server send data back
and forth to the device in the SSH
options section we'll select SSH -
because our Linux version uses SSH -
instead of SSH one there are no changes
we'll make a new authentication section
in the command line we simply make sure
that we are using the SSH script type in
the configuration section will leave
native compare selected we're going to
turn off reboot on config load this
probably doesn't make sense for a Linux
server and we don't want to reboot our
server unnecessarily anyway will allow
line by line for native command sets
this allows all commands to be executed
in a command set even if some of them
error out which may be useful when we
try to collect information from the
linux server later we're going to leave
the compare device and ikn cm checkbox
checks for network devices this box
should always be checked for normal use
but if your linux server responses are
not consistent this may cause IT MCM to
incorrectly think that IT MCM and the
Linux server are at a sink in that case
we can edit the driver and change the
setting we only have a single
configuration since we don't have the
concept of a start up command with Linux
so we'll leave the multiple config
compare checkbox unchecked and we'll
also leave the disabled config Tex one
changes unchecked this way I TM cm will
check to see if someone has changed the
Linux server configuration outside of IT
MCM before it makes a change we're going
to turn off pre writes for imports and
sinks this is the equivalent of the copy
running to start command for a Cisco
router and it really doesn't apply to a
Linux server will leave the report diffs
checkbox unchecked for import will still
see any differences when we do a
configuration synchronization and we're
going to leave the update on chain
check for our info which was our diag
section from the delay script and for
configurations so when we actually make
changes we'll get our configuration and
our information updated we'll leave the
data type as CLI since we're just
getting the output of CLI commands since
we're not going to use the telnet and
all Tom telnet access types will disable
telnet since we may use it later and
since we have no intention of having
another access type we'll simply remove
the alt telnet type this concludes the
changes we need to make to the resource
access document so we'll click next
we'll enter a description for the new
custom driver you should enter a
description that's going to make sense
to you a week a month or a year later
when you come back to try to figure out
what you created this driver for
the last screen simply shows us the
details of the driver we just created
and we can always find this information
later in the ITN CM driver management
GUI
now that we've finished creating our
driver if we refresh our drivers panel
by toggling back and forth between
screens we'll be able to see our new
driver in our top row with our Linux
server sent OS 6x and we'll notice that
this starts with CST indicating it's a
custom standard driver now it's time for
us to test our driver try to actually
import a device of this vendor type
model in OS before we can do that we
need to add credentials for the target
device into an authentication resource
we've created a custom driver test realm
just to keep things organized in this
example and we've already created a
authentication for our sent OS target
device you'll notice that we set the
filter on this to Linux as the vendor
server as a type and sent OS as the
model and we've left the OS version
wildcard if we look at this we can see
that we just have one entry with our
username or password and we also set
that password as the enable password
although for a Linux server we shouldn't
need enable password we're just doing
this to avoid a possible
nullpointerexception at execution time
in case some routine is called that
looks for an enable password value now
we need to create a device of that type
we're just going to use the linux server
that ITM CM is running one and we're
just going to name it by its host name
so we don't have to worry about name
resolution so we'll create a new network
resource
put in the IP address of our ITN cm
server and we'll select our new vendor
type model in LS we happen to know from
looking at our Red Hat ash release file
that this is a six dot X OS version
but even if we pick the five dot X at
runtime the parsing logic in the device
script that we edited would find the
right version and substitute that now
that we've created the device we'll
import it to see if our driver works
clicking on import in the context menu
opens our import network resources
wizard we can see that our device is
already selected so we'll just step
through the wizard we're going to ignore
errors we've got a authentication
resource so there's no need to override
the passwords the priority really
doesn't matter for the unit of work
we're going to create since it'll be the
only unit of work running on our example
system and we'll schedule this for
immediate execution it will just give it
a description we can look for our unit
of work in queue manager and track its
status in this case we can see that our
UOW aired out we'll take a look at the
UOW log and get an idea what the problem
is in this case it looks like there's a
problem with our command to get the
model section we did something wrong
sending the et Cie Red Hat desk release
command so we'll have to go back and
edit the driver I correct that error
we'll navigate back to the drivers panel
and from the Tools menu we'll select
edit driver this brings up our driver
wizard again and there's one driver we
can edit which is our new one we'll
navigate back to the device script panel
and we'll select SSH tab and we'll go
down to our model section we can see
that we left the equals out between the
model dot send and the command cat slash
Etsy slash Red Hat - release so we'll
correct that will check config version
to make sure we didn't make the same
error which we didn't then we can click
finish
close our editor to save our changes to
our new driver and after saving our
driver we'll go back and we'll try our
import again
you
and we'll check the status of our
currently executing unit of work
and we can see that this time we were
able to successfully import our device
now we'll go and check the configuration
data and the info data for that device
we'll have to use view native commands
to see that configuration data since
this is a standard driver and there is
not a GUI editor for the configuration
as we expected we have our config start
marker line we've got the output of CAP
slash et Cie hosts and the output of
netstat dash NR if we look at our
information data that's under the
hardware tab for historical reasons IT
MCM used to model hardware and there was
a GUI layout for the chassis however
that work has now been deferred to ITM
however IT MCM still collects the text
data in this section and we can see the
output of our /s bin / ifconfig command
here if the new driver fails when
importing the device and a basic check
of device connectivity device law on
credentials and the accuracy of your
device script editing and the new driver
don't solve the problem you can set the
driver logging level to debug to get
additional troubleshooting information
to do this edit the driver log dot
properties file in the config slash
properties directory under the ITN cm
base install location near the top of
the file change the line log4j root
logger equals error comma driver log to
log4j root log R equals debug driver log
save the file and restart itn cm when
itn cm restarts test your work against
the device again after that review the
data in the driver's log file under the
logs directory of the ITM cm base
install location
once you've done troubleshooting
remember to set driver logging back to
error level to avoid degrading IT MCN
performance
now that our new driver is working
correctly to import devices into IT NCM
we need to test to be sure that it will
correctly execute CLI commands from a
native CLI command set in order to do
that we need to create a native CLI
command set of the same v TM OS as the
new driver for our example we've created
a simple native CLI command set called
yet you limit data the vendor filter is
set to Linux the type filter is set the
server and we've left the model and OS
filters wild carded since the command
we're going to use will work on probably
any Linux server we can see that we're
just going to send the command you limit
- a the driver framework takes care of
connecting to the device sending this
command and detecting that the command
is completed successfully in this case
we're going to select a type
interrogation native command set because
we want to return results and be able to
view those results so our next step is
to apply that command set to the device
we could apply the command set from the
device or from the command set itself
using the context menu apply a native
command set this opens a wizard we can
see that the command set is already
selected and we'll just walk through the
wizard and select the device
we don't need to supply credentials
since we already have an authentication
resource and we don't really care about
the priority in this case since our
system is not very busy and we'll
schedule this command set unit of work
for immediate execution and we check the
progress of our command set in our queue
manager look at the work currently
executing and bore into our command set
and take a look at the resulting unit
for clogged we can see that a command
set has completed successfully it's sent
our command you limit - a and it got
back the response we expected for a non
rude user this concludes our example of
creating and testing a custom standard
driver with basic capabilities to back
up configuration data and to execute CLI
commands although our examples for a
Linux server creating drivers for
networked devices requires the same
basic steps